ted
the raiders in the middle of a crucial
part of their schedule where they take
on teams from the afc west
ron futrell is here with us with the
latest
so the raiders returned home to las
vegas to take on the broncos and west
coast football
is looking pretty strong right now with
the rise of the raiders
the afc west is looking better and then
you have the nfc west
which is loaded with very strong teams a
very tough division
you know by far the best division in
football right now seahawks here
to win the division they're a two minus
220 favorite
they've got that six and two record but
right behind are the cardinals and the
rams
both at five and three and the cardinals
have that win over the seahawks which is
big
uh but the rams are the second choice
they're uh playing seattle this week
so they chance to pick up some ground on
seattle
the rams are actually a one and a half
point favorite the game is in l.a
and now the raiders after that thrilling
win over the chargers on sunday
get the broncos this week this is a very
big game for them
you know fighting for that wild card
spot coming off two wins
they don't make any game easy so the
raiders are on a roll right now
trying to win their third in a row
against the broncos here on sunday
and then the week after that oh it
really gets interesting because the
raiders take on the kansas city chiefs
here to legion stadium on a sunday night
game remember
the raiders shot the chiefs at arrowhead
stadium already this year
at allegiant stadium i'm ron futuro
reporting eight sports now
coming up next here on the valley's news
leader an adorable way to end your